it's the final home game of the season
for the las vegas raiders it's been a
crazy season with
so many coveted concerns thank you so
much for joining us tonight at five
o'clock this saturday
i'm sasha loftis it's also a huge season
of disappointment with no
fans allowed in legion stadium sports
director chris matthews starts our
coverage tonight from outside allegion
and chris the raiders are hosting the
dolphins
yeah they're hosting the dolphin study
it's hard to believe this season has
come down to the final two games here at
home the home finale against the
dolphins and next week
at the denver broncos now guess who
can't wait for next year to start
of course that is raider nation you can
see raider nation
now these guys have come out all season
long you got the win city raiders here
all the raiders but over here
this guy's been here all season long
here is juan mendoza one i gotta ask you
even though no fans have really come out
you've come out
all season long i'll try to support all
raiders
i'm here all the time if they're welcome
to come by
and we're here go raiders let me ask you
now next year hopefully all of raider
nation will come to las vegas
what can fans expect what will people in
las vegas expect when the nation
descends on las vegas
oh it's going to be huge uh i can't wait
for that
we all waiting for all this coming to go
by and
hopefully next year will be a lot better
all right so it's going to be a lot of
fun next season juan mendoza and all the
crew
here's the win city raiders they're
enjoying themselves
[Applause]
there's the guy flying the flag he flies
the flag for the raiders and for the
golden knights
and over here you can see some more fans
raider nation fans
and he's got the fin he's got the
dolphin on the end of a hook right here
we'll see what happens well much more
for you coming up at six o'clock the
home finale
for your las vegas raiders taking on the
miami dolphins reporting from outside of
legion stadium
i'm chris matthews eight sports now all
right chris you have fun out there